hi this is preshtalwalker
can you use six matches to make four
triangles of equal size and equal shape
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
when you lay the matches it's very easy
to make one triangle
and you can probably make a second
triangle
but how do you make four triangles
the trick is to think in three
dimensions
if you arrange the matches in the
following shape
you create a tetrahedron
this is a shape that has four faces that
are each equilateral triangles
there are six edges in the shape
and that's how you can use six matches
to make four triangles of equal size and
equal shape did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalkar and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description